you've already been dropping bombs
incredible advice
on startups in general but let me maybe
uh go straight in and ask uh
is there advice for somebody that wants
to go big to build the big startup to
help them succeed
yeah it's very similar to the advice i
give to investors because now i
i teach angel investing because there's
so many people want to invest
and so i wrote a book on that angel and
then i do a course called angel
university that i teach six times a year
and then i have a syndicate called the
syndicate.com where i invest in
companies there's 6 500 people who are
members of that it's the largest
syndicate in the world
in fact the first deal we ever did was
com.com the meditation app we put 378
thousand dollars into it when it was a
five million dollar product
a five million dollar company so we
bought six or seven percent of the
company it's now worth two billion
so you can do the math on that we still
own five percent what year was it uh six
years ago so
probably seven yeah maybe 2015
uh 2014 and nobody else would invest in
calm yeah
but sam harris was the reason i did
because i asked sam
tell me about meditation and he's
explaining it to me and i said what
about this like do you have to have like
a mantra how does it work exactly i know
possibilities like well you know you
should just go to ucla and talk to diana
winston and like there's this whole
project there and i'm like ucla does
meditation
it's like yeah there's a mindful
institute they're like teaching people
to be
tahiti meditation and they're doing ptsd
and i'm doing brain scans
and i was like oh and then i talked to
the ucla
people and they're like it's real yeah
like we we taught phil jackson and
kobe bryant and shaquille o'neal did
you know that's how they won their
championships they meditated and i was
like
hmm if ucla is doing and sam says it's
cool
well [ __ ] it i'll put money into that
and that's the second biggest investment
in my career
after uber and it will in all likelihood
become the biggest i mean it's between
uber
robin hood and com
and long story short when i'm teaching
people to angel invest there's really
two things that you cannot
cannot fake one is a product that is
built really well
so if you look at com robinhood uber
tesla amazon
these products are transcendent
they're well constructed this
craftsmanship to them they're they're
great
products so you're saying not
fundamentally like the idea but the
execution of the actual cross-sector for
the construction the
actual product is amazing then
um there's customers and that every
business has ultimately a customer
and that customer if they are in fact
delighted by that
product that's the magic because
you need a team to build the product and
then you need customers to use the
product
and really those three vectors are
undeniable now
you could have great teams that build a
bad product doesn't happen too often
or you have customers who don't like the
product but generally speaking
a great team will build a great product
or a good product and iterate
and then eventually delight customers
and so
most people say the team is the most
important but
um there's a lot of smart people out
there and let's assume that you can have
you can raise money for your idea or you
have money or you can just convince
people to do it for free
if you make a great product and it
connects with users that's the magic you
look at clubhouse
it's actually a really well designed
product uh and that product is
connecting with customers and if you
were to talk to the customers or look at
the product
you would see a well-constructed product
and a delighted customer
and you can tell the delighted customer
by just the amount of time they use it
that's called engagement
just a fancy word for how much they use
it and snapchat when that was going
around
and they were trying to raise money they
had a fraction of the number of users
but the top maybe third were opening the
app
every hour and that nobody had ever seen
that before people were using facebook
you know a couple times a day the top
users
but nobody had ever seen people using it
every day for a hundred days in a row
every hour
and i was like what's going on here it's
like oh the ephemeral messaging
and then the streaks they had created
these streaks between people where
you know every day and then people would
be like on vacation like i just have to
open my streak and keep my street with
lex
that we chatted every day going and so
they had this like addictive nature to
it and that's why clubhouse was able to
garner so much investment
is the number of hours people were using
it every month
uh was just unbelievably off the charts
you